through your columns to your tweets we
know that you are adamantly opposed to
much of what Donald Trump has done what
he said and what he was proposing in
terms of policy but I want to ask you
this you're an economist so now you've
got to assess the economy is there any
scenario for you where Donald Trump's
fiscal policies work tax cuts on the on
the wealthier and on middle and lower
income people maybe they do meet lead to
more investment more jobs that's one
infrastructure spending we got some done
it goes through quickly that creates
jobs and maybe you reform dodd-frank
which many people say has hurt lending
to small businesses and hurt community
banks is there any positive snaring for
you that well I've been arguing for a
long time for fiscal stimulus and the
case is a lot weaker now than it was a
few years ago because we do look like
we're fairly close to full employment
but we're probably not all the way there
and there's an insurance argument for
fiscal stimulus because what if there is
a downturn and monetary you know
interest rates are still very close to
zero having a little bit of extra bump
so fiscal stimulus even though are
really badly constructive fiscal
stimulus could be a good thing now it's
really badly constructed to the extent
we have any idea what the policy is
going to be but sure there's there's
some case for that it's not now
infrastructure yeah I mean I'd be that's
a tremendous case for it but a large
infrastructure build but we don't have
any proposal and the closest thing we
have during the campaign was something
that really would have generated almost
no new infrastructure investment was
really a privatization scheme disguised
as an infrastructure scheme there wasn't
there wasn't a lot of government
spending in there at all so I don't
really believe in that part
dodd-frank know there's there's zero
evidence that dodd-frank is holding back
the economy there's a lot of evidence
that hasn't been doing good all of this
push to undo dodd-frank is just a way of
setting up the next crisis well but
small business lending and in fact the
the share of it in CNI loans has shrunk
from about 36% to about 19% small
business employment is down I think
there's you can there's a compelling
case being made that there's there are
places where bank regulations are
hurting retail customers like small
business as in it's through this small
business lending channel we have there's
a regular survey of small businesses
where they're asked about their problems
and the defraction who say that they're
having any problem getting low
that there you know is is near a
historic low there's just no evidence
all the although everything we can see
suggests that the reason that they're
not borrowing is they don't have stuff
to spend on it just that that's a really
reaching to find something that the very
people who should be complaining about
it are not in fact complaining so is the
Fed wrongheaded to think it should start
raising rates in fact Eric Rosen here
from the Boston Fed said that we could
be more than three rate hikes this year
Janet Yellen seems to be on board with
two or three don't know it doesn't know
when she's gonna start are they hitting
in the right direction
I wouldn't I mean I understand the
reasoning they're not stupid but I think
we're still we're still probably not at
full employment inflation is still not
at the two percent target and the two
percent target itself is questionable
and there's a really strong case for
letting it overshoot a bit for getting
you know as as I think it was I was the
first one to say it's not for you know
don't shoot until you see the whites of
inflation's eyes so I would not be doing
this they're they're making 2% look like
not a target but a ceiling and that's a
very bad thing given the kind of
weakness we've seen in the economy over
the past ten years the economy is that
vulnerable why not give it some more
fiscal stimulus through infrastructure
spending oh that's right I mean it was I
mean if it was infrastructure spending
and then I if it was a real
infrastructure plan then I would have to
endorse it but you know III think some
Senate Democrats have said you know
we're all for give us a real
infrastructure plan which is a safe
challenge because there's not chance